lately the pop singer demi lovato has
been on quite the journey for publicity
sorry uh i mean self-discovery after
coming out as
queer her word uh and then pansexual
she's now decided that she's
actually no she's not that she's
non-binary and shall be using they them
pronouns from this point forward
or at least until a trendier option
presents itself the mainstream media has
been all over this breaking news and the
headlines have been as weird and
headache-inducing as you might expect in
an article
a cbs news article confusingly titled
demi lovato announces they are
non-binary and changing their pronouns
they reported the following this is a
reading from the article now it says
see if you can follow along it says
singer demi lovato has announced
that they are non-binary and are
changing their pronouns to they them
they said that the revelation followed a
quote a lot of healing and
self-reflective work
in a twitter video early wednesday
morning introducing their new podcast
the pop singer
says they don't identify as male or
female on their podcast lovato said
that quote it would mean the world if
people used their correct pronouns but
they will be accepting if people
accidentally use
she her pronouns and they just want
want them to be making the effort i i ca
i can't even follow and i'm reading it
now look if you went into a coma
sometime in the year 2015 or so and had
just now woken up the preceding
paragraph
would be rather bewildering you would be
forgiven for assuming that demi lovato
is the name for some sort of group or
collective
if you heard someone say i saw demi
lovato in concert
and they were really good you would
immediately conclude that demi lovato is
an entire band not one single person
this conclusion would be justified as it
would be based on the rules
of the english language little would you
know that demi lovato is a single
individual
and also by the way that she's not that
good in concert for the record
here is lovato herself um or themselves
explaining why she slash they
has slash have made this change
this is 4d with demi lovato
living in the fourth dimension means
existing consciously and both time and
space
but for me it means having conversations
that transcend the typical discourse
i want to take this moment to share
something very personal with you
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them
i feel that this best represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person
i both know i am and still am
discovering
in this first episode i'm excited to
share with you
what this means to me and what it may
look like for other people
i want to make it clear that i'm still
learning and coming into myself
and i don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
now it's it's helpful that she began her
explanation the way that she did so that
it would be painfully clear that the
whole thing is nothing but ridiculous
psychobabble
living in the fourth dimension means
existing consciously in both time and
space
what is that supposed to mean what other
option do we have but to exist
consciously in both time and space
can i exist consciously in space but not
time can i exist in neither space nor
time can i be
a spaceless timeless shapeless vapor
floating aimlessly through an eternal
abyss
i suppose i suppose it's only a matter
of time before demi lovato
assumes that identity for herself or for
themselves
as i've often argued the proliferation
of these ambiguous alternative
identities is really
when it comes down to it a proliferation
of narcissism lovato can't explain
what identifying as non-binary means
she can't tell us how she arrived at
this conclusion about herself
none of this can be made coherent
because it doesn't really mean anything
what she's trying to say actually is
that is that she is more complex
and interesting than the average person
she's not she's not
sure who she is exactly but she's sure
that whoever she is
she must not be what everyone else is
her identity transcends
all labels except the 15 different
labels she's given herself over the last
six months
but look that's all her concern she's
free to play whatever word game she
wants to play
she's free to make whatever claims about
herself that she wants to make
the problem is that we are not simply
asked
to leave people alone and let them live
how they want and identify how they want
that used to be the request or what
seemed like a request at the time to
some people
just let let people live how they want
let let them be right
it's not the case anymore it's now
demanded that we participate
that we take active roles in affirming
and supporting the self-identity of
strangers
i'm fine with leaving people alone if i
heard through the grapevine that my
neighbor three doors down
identifies as a cantaloupe i'm not gonna
go knock on his door
and scream at him to leave his
cantaloupe fantasies behind you're not a
cantaloupe damn it
i wouldn't do that but if i'm told that
i must
in any way affirm or reinforce the
cantaloupe delusion
then i will have to respectfully decline
he can think whatever he wants but he
can't force me to think it
or to pretend that i think it i'm not
intruding on his life when i protest or
resist
such an imposition i am stopping him
from intruding on mine
he might live in a world where men can
be cantaloupe cantaloupes but but i
don't
i live in the real world and i'd like to
remain here
that's my lifestyle choice and i will
insist that it be respected
and so it goes with pronouns a pronoun
is a grammatical construct it's part of
language
it's not a pet that you can own it's not
your pet goldfish
it's not a fashion accessory that you
can wear
you don't get your own pronouns just as
you don't get your own prepositions or
your own adverbs
i suppose a man might have a special
affinity for the preposition
on but that doesn't change what the word
on
means if he is not sitting on
a chair but says that he identifies as
sitting on it because his preferred
preposition is on
that wouldn't change his actual physical
relationship
to the chair in real life and by
demanding that we all pretend that the
word
on means off and off means on he is the
one trying to impose himself
on us or off of us as the case may be
for the sake of preserving language as a
tool for conveying meaning
which is the whole reason why language
exists in the first place
we would have to resist those efforts
in the english language the word he
is the pronoun that refers to males she
refers to females
that's how it works in english they
refers either to multiple people
or to an unknown person it would be
perfectly valid to say for example
look someone left their wallet here i
hope they come back for it
or i hope they don't come back for it if
you're a less honest person
but it would not be valid to say look my
friend george left their wallet here i
hope they come back for it
that doesn't make any sense because i
know who george
is i know that he's male i know that
he's only one person not siamese twins
the word they in that context would be
deceptive and confusing
and it would fail to convey meaning
which again
is the entire point of language
in fact they in that context let's say
that my friend george
is non-binary whatever exactly that
means and i use the word they
what am i actually saying what what
meaning am i conveying
because he's a male and he's only one
person
so they in that context is referring to
his
perception of himself
it's referring to his feelings about
himself
but that is not what pronouns are
supposed to do
pronouns are not concerned with your
self-perception
or how you feel we
we have language we have words that can
talk about that
but when i but when we are using
pronouns
it is a reference to who an individual
actually is
not how they see themselves not how they
feel that's irrelevant to the pronoun
now it's true that language evolves over
time but
the preferred pronoun phenomenon is is
not an example of linguistic evolution
let's be very clear about this
the people pushing this change are
indeed pushing it
they're not just observing that it's
already happened
it is a top-down change it's not an
organic development
the cultural powers that be have decided
that certain words should no longer mean
what they have always meant
though they can't be bothered to tell us
what those words should mean now instead
they are by forcing coercion attempting
to remove the meaning from words
without replacing the words with new
meaning
see language develops naturally over
time
in order to better convey meaning in our
case
language is being manipulated
intentionally in order to make it
less meaningful that is a very
very different thing
why does all this matter i would hope
it'd be obvious by now
language matters we cannot have a human
society without it
truth matters we cannot have a society
worth living in
without it we are witnessing an attack
on both language
and truth and thus on society
and that matters and it only requires a
little backbone
to oppose it well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content